Here's a sketch of SAAM. Assuming that we have already gone through
an architectural design process and if we produce some artifacts like diagrams.
So we generate that architecture. We also generate some scenarios.
Now these are not primarily usage scenarios, or we could think of them as,
as elaborated usage scenarios. Where instead of looking at it from the outside,
external view, we're looking for it internally. So for example if,
if the external request is by the user to compute some result,
the generated scenario here that we,
the team provides is which elements of the architecture are required. To,
be involved in providing that functionality. And in what order. That is,
we essentially are going to, walk through the diagram and
see how that particular usage of the system impacts the architecture.
This is particularly important if what we're talking about is a new scenario.
That is imagine the system that was architected one way and
we want to add a new a new, a new functionality to it.
Imagine also that maybe there are thoughts on different ways of doing this. So
if we had alternative proposals. Each are provided
in the form of some kind of diagram, we could walk through the two diagrams and
see which one, in which one, there's more impact of the change.
We might want to go with the solution which has the, the lesser impact. And
so imagine this all happening in some kind of design review meeting,
in which we systematically go through that proposed changes.
The proposed architectural responses to them. And use the gathered
information to come, to come to some kind of conclusion about the way forward.